-♪ Hop Quiz,
Hop, Hop Quiz ♪
♪ Hop Quiz ♪
-Playing tonight, we have
the host of "The Tonight Show,"
Mr. Jimmy Fallon!
-Hey! What's happening?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And from
"The Secret Life of Pets 2,"
the very handsome
Mr. Kevin Hart.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-What's going on?
-It's a fun game.
You're gonna love this game.
-Higgins, how does it work?
-Well, here's how it works.
I'll ask both of you
animal trivia questions, right?
And if you get a correct answer,
you win a rabbit.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
If you lose,
you're opponent gets a rabbit.
So, Kevin, you're up first.
-Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Before we go.
Just let me --
Let me make sure
I understand this.
So, if I get
the question right...
-Yes, you get a rabbit on you.
-If I get it right,
I get the rabbit on me.
-If you get it wrong,
it goes on Jimmy.
-I'm changing the rule!
I'm changing the rule.
[ Laughter ]
-I just want to know
how to not get the rabbit.
If I get --
[ Laughter ]
If I get it right --
-If you get it right,
you do not get --
-You get the rabbit.
You get the rabbit.
-That's correct.
-What kind of rabbit is --
I've never seen --
-A Boston flimmer.
[ Laughter ]
-What -- What -- What is --
-He made it up.
Come on.
-Okay, cool, let's go.
I'm ready.
-Aww.
-That doesn't look like --
-It's a little sick.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
Kevin, you're first up.
What is the loudest animal
on Earth?
Is it, A -- don't laugh --
sperm whale,
B, hyena, or C, cicada.
Loudest animal on Earth.
-This is just a question.
-Yes, and you answer
one of those.
-Is the sperm whale --
is he -- is he releasing?
Like, is he...
[ Laughter ]
-I'm gonna cover
this bunny's ears.
-I'm asking.
I'm asking a question.
-Oh, my God.
Don't look.
-Is it --
I'm asking a question.
-If that's what you want --
You know what?
If that's the first image
that popped in your head, sure.
-Okay. All right. Well,
I'm gonna answer this question
based off of my knowledge
and my personal experience.
I can only assume that
the sperm whale is in there
because he's in a position
where something's happening.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-And I don't know
what a whale sounds like,
but if it's going down,
I can only imagine.
[ Laughter ]
I'ma go sperm whale.
-That is correct!
-Ha!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, now you --
There you go.
-Yeah.
-There you go. That's fine.
-Oh, no.
O-o-oh, no.
-Okay.
-Oh, no.
-Next question's for Jimmy.
-Jimmy.
-Do we know what to do
if the rabbit start
acting a fool when we get it?
Do we just let it go?
-Let it go. It'll be good.
-Y'all just go get it.
So we just let it go.
-Yeah.
-Okay. All right.
-Some are more sick than others.
[ Laughter ]
Which of these bats is native
to the tropical forests
of Southeast Asia?
-Are you joking me?
[ Laughter ]
"What's the loudest animal --
a whale or a dog?"
Is it A, dog-faced bat,
B, ghost-faced bat...
-Oh, I know this.
-...or, C, hairy-faced bat?
[ Laughter ]
-This is insane and rigged.
But if I get it wrong,
oh, I get a bunny.
-If you get it wrong,
you get a bunny.
If you get it right,
Kevin gets a bunny.
-I'm gonna say --
These bats are native
to the tropical forests
of Southeast Asia?
I'm gonna say, uh...
ghost-faced bat?
-Is that your final answer?
[ Buzzer ]
-No!
-Sorry.
It was the hairy-faced bat.
-I was just gonna shout out
to Wu-Tang.
[ Laughter ]
-Jimmy gets the bunny.
Don't de Blasio that bunny.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
[ Air horns blare ]
See? There you go.
Oh! You hear that sound?
Did you hear that sound?
-Yes.
-That means it's time
for Double Hoperty,
where questions
are now worth two rabbits.
-Hold on for a second.
-What's that?
-What the --
What is that?
-That's a rabbit.
-That ain't --
-That's a Netherlands giant.
-That ain't no rabbit.
-It's a man in a suit.
[ Laughter ]
-That ain't -- [ Laughs ]
That ain't no rabbit.
Do they get bigger than that?
-Yeah.
The next one --
Wait till you see the next one.
-Ay, don't bring no rabbit --
-Well, guess what.
Kevin, you're lucky,
'cause this question's for you.
-Hey, man.
-Comes with two rabbits.
What?
-What country invented the sport
of rabbit jumping...
-What?
-...known as kaninhop?
Was it, A, Iceland...
-What?
-...B, Sweden...
-...or, C, New Zealand?
Kaninhop.
Sport of rabbit jumping.
-Kaninhop, dude.
-You know this, man.
You know this!
-Come on.
Kaninhop, dude.
-Iceland, Sweden...
-Don't bring no rabbit out here
bigger than that, man.
[ Laughter ]
-You're gonna get two rabbits.
-All right. Um...
You know what?
I'm big on common sense.
-Sure.
-So all I gotta do
is use common sense.
Why would a rabbit --
Why would a rabbit
be in Iceland?
I don't see that happening.
[ Laughter ]
You know, it's cold,
so let's X that out.
Rabbits don't like cold.
It's --
You know what?
If I had to guess --
I ain't even guessing.
This is the real answer --
it's Sweden.
I know exactly where it is.
It's Sweden.
[ Ding! ]
-Yes!
-Sweden.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There you go, Jimmy.
The rabbits are
Steve Moody and Helen Weatherby.
-Oh [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
Oh [bleep]
-There you go.
-Aah! Aah!
-There you go. You got that?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, that's the devil!
That's the devil!
Look at that rabbit eyes!
Yo, look at that rabbit eyes!
[ Laughter ]
That's the exorcist!
That's the --
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
-I think we're gonna go
to the final question.
-That rabbit dead!
That rabbit ain't alive, Jimmy!
[ Laughter ]
-Okay!
-Oh, my God.
-Final question goes to Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
In March of this year,
what animal was elected mayor
of Fair Haven, Vermont?
-Hey, hey, man.
-Was it --
-Don't bring -- Don't bring
no rabbits worse than that.
[ Laughter ]
-That was --
-I'm not holding no rabbit.
[ Laughter ]
I ain't holding no rabbit
with black eyes, man.
-Kevin, you only
have to hold one.
-Only hold one.
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
-You know which one
you're gonna hold, man.
-Yeah.
The devil eye.
-Hey -- Hey, man.
Y'all need to go
put that rabbit up.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, Jimmy, ready?
Goat, chipmunk, or beaver.
Mayor of Fair Haven, Vermont.
-Vermont --
-Goat, chipmunk, or beaver.
-Vermont,
I would say they have
Ben & Jerry's,
a lot of milk, cheese.
I'm gonna say, A, goat.
[ Ding! ]
-That is a correct answer!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Kevin.
-Just wait, just wait.
-Orson Cooper and Sarah Belmont
are two little bunnies.
-Just wait, just wait,
just wait! Wait.
Wait.
Let me sit down.
Just wait.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
I think it went poop.
Kevin, you are the winner!
-I know I'm the winner.
Give me a second.
Just put --
Put it right here.
Just let me --
[ Booing ]
All right, all right,
all right, all right.
Where his neck at?
Come on, man.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
Oh!
Oh [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Everybody,
my thanks to Kevin Hart
and all these adorable rabbits.
You're the winner, buddy!
More "Tonight Show"
after the break!
Stick around, everybody.
We'll be right back.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪